Hollywood has always managed to cash in
with genre pictures when it comes to
cinemas biggest bang for the buck
however Studios big and small continue
to mine the spooky blood-spattered realm
of horror few filmmakers have been able
to get more from a meager budget than
Eduardo Sanchez and Daniel Merrik when
the pair set out to turn their 35 page
outline into a feature film in 1997 they
cobbled together a mere $25,000 that
modest budget gave the first-time
filmmakers just enough loot to hire
three completely unknown actors dropped
them off in the woods with a couple of
borrowed cameras and hoped that their
efforts and an out-of-the-box concept
would be enough to turn that rough
outline into a genuinely upsetting
found-footage chiller it was more than
enough the buzz behind the Blair Witch
Project was so real that audiences
flocked to theaters the summer of 1999
to see it many still believed it to be
legit found footage which had a lot to
do with a radical marketing campaign
that never quite confirmed or denied the
movie's authenticity that the film
itself is such a viscerally unsettling
experience in its own right
only fanned the flames and the
combination turned blair witch into an
unexpected box-office behemoth with
nearly two hundred and fifty million
dollars in worldwide ticket sales it
ranks among the most profitable movies
ever produced John Carpenter's Halloween
stands as one of the most revered horror
movies ever made the near-flawless 1978
film essentially gave birth to the
slasher genre but it also paved the way
for meticulously crafted character
driven scares and as it happens
carpenters groundbreaking slasher more
than earns its spot on this list because
the horror master himself had a mere
three hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars to bring his frightful vision to
life NAT slim budget is of course part
of what helped Halloween stand out it
forced carpenter to use innovative
techniques like that Steadicam
prospective opening or taking a simple
jumpsuit and a William Shatner mask and
turning it into a seemingly inhuman
monster though carpenter and as many
ghastly creations have continued to
spook us over the years few have
unsettled us quite like this
micro-budget masterpiece has and even
fewer have genuinely stood the test of
time with such monstrous eloquence these
days we all know jason blum blum house
productions as the powerhouse behind
genre hits like sinister splits get out
and the purge prior to 2007 however Blum
house was known mostly as a company that
wanted to produce high
genre movies with little to no budget
with a few non-professional actors a
home video camera a 7-day shooting
schedule and a fifteen thousand dollar
budgets Paranormal Activity didn't just
fit the parameters for what Blum House
was trying to do it essentially became
the blueprints Oren Paley's haunting
tale of a young couple tormented by a
malevolent demonic presence was the film
that officially put Blum housed on the
Hollywood map once the film ran through
Paramount Pictures and into wide
distribution Paranormal Activity scared
up an astonishing 193 million dollars at
the box office I think anyone sitting
disabilities being successful for the
record those numbers also earned the
film the title of the most profitable
movie ever made
with eyebrow racing numbers like that it
wasn't long before people started
throwing the word sequel around instead
Paley and Blum houses start no budget
vision birthed an entire franchise to
date the Paranormal Activity verse has
spawned a total of five sequels that
have brought in close to a billion
dollars in worldwide ticket sales not a
bad return on an initial $15,000
investment though he's dabbled almost
exclusively in the realm of tentpole
Pictures over the last couple of decades
Sam Raimi spent their early days of his
career as a low-budget Jon ray Wiz with
a dizzying pension for delivering both
big laughs and bloody carnage with equal
fervor 1981 s ghoul fest the Evil Dead
delivered a genuinely disturbing
altogether unforgettable cinematic
experience Raimi put together the
effects-heavy film with the reported
budget of only three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars while it didn't exactly
set the domestic box-office ablaze the
Evil Dead more than turned to tidy
profit upon release and helps set a new
standard for the growing wave of shock
and schlock horrid devotees more than
anything approved Raimi to be a
filmmaker of singular cinematic vision
and it remains ground zero for the wild
stylistic flourishes unapologetic camp
and relentless bloodletting that would
inform virtually every one of his films
thereafter oh and did we mention that
the Evil Dead also made a bona fide cult
sensation of its chisel chin star Bruce
Campbell
make no mistake when George a Romero's
zombie classic Night of the Living Dead
hit theaters back in 1968 it was like
nothing that had ever come before it's
the film was so singular and vision and
execution that it basically invented a
new horror sub-genre and moviegoers have
been devouring tales of the flesh-eating
undead ever since coming to get you
Barbara
of course Night of the Living Dead
wasn't always meant to be game changing
horror Romero's feature debut was
originally supposed to be a sci-fi
comedy about hot rodding aliens when
budget constraints made that concept all
but impossible the idea pivoted to
flesh-eating aliens it finally ended up
on undead flesh-eating humans which
allowed the production to make full use
of its paltry 114 thousand dollar budget
to say Romero got his money's worth
would be an understatement
the film's gritty style grisly special
effects inviting social commentary hit
home with genre fans and casual film
goers alike and brought in a staggering
18 million dollars at the box office
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]